baby videos of the dog in the baby
babies and dogs I love crying me too I'm
really emotional almost all the time
I cried in public a lot I don't cry
unless it's like super personal I'm an
easy cry I think I'm more likely to cry
on in frustration than something that's
at my cry reflex it's tighter than my
sphincter I will my pants but I will not
cry in front of you
[Music]
we're so stirring the whole thing Oh
classic Forrest Gump first fat man the
romance of all romances okay okay oh
this might get you this might get Dan I
don't know
the scene is so beautiful very well a
shot Oh your goes I don't even like this
movie I have like blue balls of crying
like I really want to be crying after
that scene but I'm not why is the bad
scene of lions is the bad scene help
James Earl Jones I don't know why he
does this like they're related it's a
game of Thrones right here
Oh God kitchen oh I can't watch and find
the body
he's always dead oh there it goes
[Music]
it's the dead scene from Marley & Me
nope
no that's unfair I know it's a lab I do
have a dog similar to this and that's
sad the dog is acting Maya enjoying even
the status of members allows you to
Elsinore the happiest moments like some
even more pure and more great for what
they are but if you only experienced
happy moments your life would be very
like surface-level you know we each deal
with our emotions in our own way yeah
and I respect yours I mean you watch
someone crying you're watching them at
their most vulnerable people like to see
a reaction that they feel like is not
fake and it's not coerce one of the few
emotions that we have like a physical
representation where we can say that
real that was rough